the former CDC director that's dr. Tom
Frieden says the fight against the
corona virus is just beginning
he told lawmakers yesterday the u.s.
death toll could reach 100,000 by the
end of this month right now the death
toll is a little over 74,000 dr. Anthony
foul she was asked to testify at that
hearing but the White House said no to
that dr. Frieden is a president and CEO
of the initiative resolve to save lives
which works to prevent epidemics good
morning to you dr. Frieden it's really
good to see you listen I know that you
are not a man who was careless with his
words you have trip good morning you
have tremendous expertise you are not
careless with your words so what caused
you to make that prediction yesterday
what are you seeing
unfortunately the numbers are just
inescapable with so many infections of
people in the past two to three weeks
and the death rate that we're seeing
among those infected is just a
calculation that tragically the number
of deaths will continue for the next few
weeks the thing that concerns me even
more is that bad as this is we're just
at the beginning we still don't have
widespread infection and if infection
causes immunity it really would be still
a very small proportion of Americans or
protected
therefore the virus has essentially an
open field run what we have to do is
restart the economy without rekindling
the epidemic but dr. Frieden everybody
seems to be working so hard to flatten
the curve clearly we're not doing enough
you haven't you have another plan you
have a better idea there are a couple
things we have to do one is to make sure
we do a better job protecting those most
at risk including in congregate
facilities that includes nursing homes
which are being devastated by this all
over the country prisons all
correctional facilities homeless
shelters meatpacking and other close
quarters where people work that that
kind of context is resulting in
explosive spread and it doesn't stay
there it spreads into the community as
well but flattening the curve by staying
at home is just one part of the equation
of what
we have to do that's buying us time to
build systems so we can protect our
healthcare workers better so we can box
the virus in by testing isolation
contact tracing and quarantine those are
the four steps of boxing the virus in if
we get all of them right we can come out
much more safely yeah we always keep
hearing about testing testing testing
yesterday at the White House a press
secretary said it's nonsensical where
was her words to get everyone tested
because she said listen an hour later
the the results could change an hour
later you could contact the virus does
she have a point testing is not a single
thing one of the things that I think we
have to understand is this is a very
complicated disease to fight it requires
a comprehensive approach and testing is
one part of that approach currently we
don't have enough tests in this country
even for the highest priority people but
even without that there's a lot we can
do by improving isolation ramping up
contact tracing and ensuring that
contacts are quarantined also thinking
about how to re-engineer our environment
so that there's less risk fewer doors to
open with our hands ways to push
elevator buttons without possibly
getting contaminated making sure that
we're sanitizing our hands when we enter
buildings thinking about how to how to
work more effectively while physically
distancing there is not a conflict
between economics and public health
there is the need to reduce the virus
burden so we can get our economy back
and there's a need to get the economy
back and our health care system back so
we don't lose lives from the
interruptions that kovat is causing the
the AP is reporting that the Trump
administration is deciding to let the
state's decide when it's time to reopen
instead of going along with the CDC
guidelines do you think that's the right
call here these are tough decisions what
we need to do is reopen gradually learn
lessons try to figure out how to do that
while protecting the most vulnerable
people recognizing that there are
important economic
activities that need to resume
recognizing that people can go outside
safely in most environments recognizing
that there are workplace changes that
can allow workplaces to reopen without
risking the lives of workers and others
all right dr. Frieden thank you very
very much sir for your time this morning